American voters are smart but they're
also human so they're gonna have an
emotional response to some of these
devices right yeah what would you have
them do when they have that response to
something they see online so if somebody
if something is presented to you on
whatever your social media platform of
choice is whether it's a meme or whether
it's an article or just somebody's post
look at it say okay this is they're
making a claim can I verify it so hop
over into your favorite search engine
try to verify it if it's not true yeah
do you really want to be prop
propagating or promulgating this story
but it was alright it's hard it's art
but let me also give this social media
company some credit I think particularly
where we were in 2016 there's been a
significant amount of effort on the part
of the companies to identify this these
campaigns take them off but also provide
more transparency in terms of this is a
political ad or whatever it is what you
know making you and me as consumers of
this information make them more informed
informed consumer you're getting the
support you need from Facebook
absolutely yeah so we all are making
decisions based on imperfect information
but there's enough sort of indicators of
what a suspicious activity inauthentic
activity and we want we want those
channels to open up between the
government and the private sector so
Facebook is doing what it needs to do to
identify fake accounts and fake
information I think they've been on a
roll lately that's for sure
what about Twitter is Twitter doing
enough they're not gonna run political
ads they announce but you go on Twitter
and everything else on true that you
want to find is on there so I think I
think Twitter's also done a good job
again is there a lot of people would be
surprised to hear well I I think it
could could more be done absolutely you
know we've got this is it summed up in
what how do you define good job in this
I think this is one of those things
where I think the more transparency we
can provide to consumers or you as you
navigate a platform whether it's Twitter
or Facebook or whatever you know to
inform you or me or whomever of how do I
evaluate this account how can I
determine the legitimacy or the
authenticity
of this information and as it's being
provided to me I think that's the goal
and they're moving in the right
direction
you've got the president's campaign and
the president surrogates promoting
messages from Russian operatives this is
according to the molar report you've got
the president's son retweeting a Russian
operative and you've got the President
himself more than a hundred and forty
times retweeting on verified accounts on
Twitter many of which are later
suspended for conspiracy theories and
extremist content how do you deal with
that it seems like the very thing you're
fighting is is happening at the highest
levels of our government my core area of
focus is the election infrastructure the
systems the folks that their core area
but you're also focused on again of
building awareness building resilience
there's there other parts of the federal
government that are engaged in this
space of bringing in intelligence about
this is a Russian actor that's pushing
this theme that's able to share that
with the social media platforms to take
it down you're trying to defend
confidence in our elections and in our
democratic institutions the president
sometimes tweets baseless theories about
voter fraud is that undermining your
election I you know I ultimately where
we are is getting information out to the
people out to the election officials so
again they can make their own
evaluations of whoever it is we have to
operate below the headlines outside of
the space of you know whatever the the
training posts are so that again the
average American has the base of
information the base of critical
thinking skills to to make their own
decisions 92% of votes cast on Election
Day 2020 you think we'll have a paper
backup which means there checkable yeah
that's that's the way the the upgrades
are working right now it looks like some
of the states and then in 16 and even 18
that didn't have a paper ballot back up
they should have paper ballot backups by
2020 again that's important so that if
if you detect something suspicious you
can go grab the paper you can run an
audit on top of it and get to again a
degree of confidence one thing I've said
before is is what's the purpose of an
election
it's not to prove to the winner who won
it's to convince the loser he lost he or
she lost so it's important that we can
go back to the tape we can pull the
records and we can say all right here's
how it went down and we can validate the
outcome how confident are you that you
can say yes to that question in 2020
I'm significantly more confident than
where we were I think it's 16 even 18